do you think there are too many
superhero shows and movies and yes there
were none yeah I do think there's too
many so what do you do about that um but
I don't think it's it's not it's it's
much less a problem of too many what's
happened is people have gotten really
lazy with their superhero stories they
have gotten the place where oh it's a
it's a superhero let's make a movie
about it you know and they make oh let's
make a sequel because the first one did
pretty well and they aren't thinking
about why is this story special what
makes this story stand apart from other
stories what is the story at the heart
of it all why is this character
important what makes this story
different that it it fills a need for
people in theaters to go see you know or
on television and that's a hard thing
and I think that is just that that's
kind of gotten you know people have
gotten a little lazy and there's a lot
of you know Biff pow bam stuff happening
in in movies